okay
good so hello everyone
um i am uh i'm greg hill um
i know most of you i think from last
year um
the ones i don't i hope to know shortly
um i wanted to take a quick minute and
do
start off with the pledge of allegiance
we'll do that on at every meeting
um if everybody why don't uh bob you
want to
lead us off here sure
well i i even have a flag here like this
oh well i got one right over there okay
here we go
justice
if i was technologically advanced i
would just be able to post
up a nice waving flag or something like
that but
it didn't work um anyway uh
i wanted to aside from me i wanted to be
able to
officers i guess uh bob greene
is for me over in the upper right corner
will be vice chair
there's bob's hand and uh and our clerk
will be vanessa sheehan um
vanessa's probably um
new to everyone here um i've never met
vanessa in in person we've had quite a
few phone calls vanessa is a
freshman representative so we'll have
every chance in the world to
uh to play dastardly tricks on vanessa
here along the way
um vanessa why don't yeah if you
wouldn't mind uh
and i am i'm still a little curious too
i don't know
um i've not heard who will be the the
um uh ranking member on the democratic
level are you
i am okay i thought so so
uh we have to call you ex-chairman or
um chairman emeritus or something like
that
uh janet yeah uh
what do you want me to say what would
you like
okay i'll call you ranking member how's
that
yes i'm yeah i'm janet wahl i'm the
ranking member i'm in my 18th term
and very happy to be with this committee
good group of people we've got some
interesting issues
this year doug ray is a deputy ranking
damn is doug
available yep right there
yep hi dad um hello that's that's
important
uh and and most of this conversation is
for the folks that
are our new colleagues more than
anything
everyone else um our old pals and
and we've already heard this probably 15
times
each this is one of the most experienced
groups i think that um exists in the
house if you
added up everybody's hours of service
which um
is a good and a bad thing it's a
double-edged sword for the uh
for their their freshman representatives
um
part of that is good because you'll be
able to
um learn from some real experienced
representatives obviously the bad part
is
um we may tend to talk in
in um shorthand at some point and uh
and we may tend to go a little faster
than
you may like so i'm giving you
open invitation at this point to um
stop us at any point um and
and ask you know where are we what are
we doing
it's actually one of the reasons that i
asked vanessa to be
our clerk uh because i figure vanessa
will be sitting
next to me and can jab me with a sharp
pen and say
stop you i don't know what you're saying
please slow down or do some of those
things so
um this is this is gonna be
a learning curve for a lot of us um
because of the zoom and and the way that
we're operating
but but we have a slight advantage the
people that have been here
before because we know at least some of
the process
um if you can think about the the uh
the poor freshmen um they've got to
learn the process and
um incorporate all of their zooms at the
same time
and and as um we just heard a few
minutes ago
some of this is still yet to be ironed
out
so um we're we're all in the same boat
so feel free anytime anytime there's a
question
to just uh just stop us
and and find out what's going on um we
used to have a rep named david murakami
some of us remember him
david was a rep from nashua
i steal from him frequently
um a line that he used um starting any
meeting
and it and he used to say i'm really
good with names
and i'm really good with faces i'm just
not really good at putting the two of
them together
so i'll do everything i can
to make sure i know everyone
i would it's a little more difficult
with zoom
than it is with individual meeting of
people
um i'm much more
used to being able to talk to somebody
in the hallways of the lob
and and getting to know them that way
it's it it's impossible on zoom i think
um and i think that's one of the
problems with it that
that we'll find it that legislating
isn't as easy as it
used to be when you see somebody in the
um i also need to
i would be remiss if i didn't um make
sure
everyone realized that uh we have
probably well not probably we have
the top committee researcher in the
whole organization maybe in the world
so we are blessed with having
pam smarling here with us today
for for everyone that um
has not met pam i encourage you to take
a few minutes and do that
pam um as our researcher
will be well i should let pam describe
what she does rather than putting words
into her
into her mouth go ahead pam if you have
a minute
absolutely that's what i'm here for um
and you'll all realize that you've
you've also got a chairman
that's prone to hyperbole but that's
the way yeah that's true that is true so
um i i am pam smarling i i
serve as the researcher for the
committee and a resource in general
i mean as legislation is filed
with the committee i provide background
research legislative history
whatever the chairman you know would
like
that's that's possible to obtain um
i try to give to you in advance of the
hearing um
if that's how the question comes or if
it's after the hearing sometimes a
question is raised then
and i can answer after the fact before
you vote on the bill clearly
i do work you know it's an important for
you to know that i work for three other
you know committees the house commerce
committee
executive departments and administration
and election law
um so they are very busy committees and
and i
all like voted to be
in on all the places at once but i am
accessible to you by email
is probably the best way or or certainly
phone
um and i've been around for a while i've
been around for
over 30 years so i i do have some
some uh extensive background files
so i look forward to working with all of
you and going forward
um as as the one thing that i will
mention here is
um access to pam and and
access to pam's work
i'm requiring all of that come through
me
that is that's pretty standard operating
procedure in here that
the chair needs to know what's going on
and pam doesn't need uh
whatever we have 15 masters um
that that doesn't help pam and it
doesn't help the process of the work
um so anything comes through me that
would be great
um we also have a committee assistant
um and i have to confess i've not met
carrie before um some of you may
i i am hearing great things
and so i don't think we'll have
obviously any issues same rules
kerry is um is assigned to us
kerry also has other committees which i
don't know do you know pam the other
committees that she is
i don't know no okay um
but at some point we'll meet carrie as
well and um
and have her introduce herself to all of
us
then we so i guess from there where i
want to head
most everyone here is anxious i'm sure
to hear about two topics
um committee hearings and executive
sessions
um committee hearings are going to be
set up in a
in a hybrid model i would call it and i
should point out too
everything i'm going to tell you from
here on out is as i understand it
now there are some things that are still
being ironed out i believe
but we will be operating committee
hearings on a hybrid
model hopefully some of us will
be in the lob i plan to always be in the
lob
for hearings um
you can certainly zoom in to the
hearings and we'll operate kind of
as we are right now i guess um
there are plans for and i think they
were installed yesterday or today do you
know pam the
air exchangers that um i saw them on
friday being
carried into the rooms okay well there
you go you're ahead of me
um i thought they were coming in uh um
maybe they said they would be activated
as of today right
or just in boxes you know so it wasn't
wasn't
installed but they were so the theory is
that that will
um make make us safe
um i
so the option still exists for hearings
where
um the public will be um
uh on zoom we will um
have some members in person that's
that's how that will stand and that's
why it's important for me to get used to
or or bob as our technological uh
leader um to figure out how to promote
people to
um to being able to talk and to provide
testimony after all that is
our uh raise on that that's our reason
to be here
um to hear from public and uh and to
pay attention everything else
from the committee hearing portion
um committee hearings will be as normal
um we will do virtually everything we've
always done
we will be attentive we will um
not be i i'm certain none of us will be
um balancing our checkbooks or or
competing with facebook or eating cocoa
crispies while we're watching
um any of our
any of our people coming and testifying
i will also ask them for this
the same courtesy um
i don't need you know parking dogs and
every other thing in the background
while we're trying to pay attention to
what they're
they're doing um i also i'm a stickler
on making sure that the information that
they give us is
um is pertinent and is not re
repetitive um if at all possible i
understand that uh
some people may come in and not see what
has been taught
talked about earlier so we may have to
put up with some of it but um
likewise i don't think it's a good idea
as i talk about
cocoa crispies i don't think it's a good
idea for us to have anything
on our desks that appear like we are not
paying attention to
um the panelists so if we are or the
attendees actually
um so you know it would be great if um
if we didn't have uh anything
um like kung pao chicken or something
for lunch or
or a mixing bowl or anything that we're
doing trying to
multitask we are here to see those
attendees and listen to their
them educate us um everything else works
the same you um
if you can get my attention with a
raised hand i'll make sure you're on a
list and you're called and you can ask
the attendees any
questions you want um follow-ups are all
the same
everything comes through the chair just
like we've always done
i'm hopeful that i can make this work as
easily and as seamlessly as it always
has
if i can do half as good a job as
our previous chairperson then i'm be
tickled pink so um that's
that's great up there's a hand go
whatever
yeah good how are you i'm representative
beth richards i think this is our first
time to kind of
meet yes um in semi-person but uh
quick question to follow up on um the
hybrid model
and um would and your comment about the
kung pao chicken
um do you have to be kung pao chicken
thank you
yeah go ahead um but uh
do you if we are hybrid in do you want
us
face like this um potentially a
background or
are we able to just be name only or
a stock photo so
for my preference it would be great if
if the attendees actually saw who they
are it's a little off-putting for me
um to just have a symbol uh
you know right now all i'm seeing of
janet is just a telephone symbol
um i i think
we should try to make this as much as
possible
as a real hearing um i think we should
be
um having people be able to talk to all
of us
even though we look like the brady bunch
up here um
it is i think it's important to have
yeah sure um right now i'm in my
business
um alone in my office
but there will be times i imagine
my children are in a hybrid model as
well
with their school and so when we all get
on um
if i'm in the home situation depending
on the date
um there i imagine
and have experienced that it would be
better for me at times to be able to
turn off my videos so that
if they need to be doing something that
demands more
so um can i we find it
perfectly fine okay so can i understand
who is saying
to the best of our ability um to be
present
and at times when we can't either via
phone
or for streaming or other things to
be a name or a picture right as i
anticipate it we will all be
muted um with with the exception of me
probably um and then um
and then so if if your children are
um interrupting you they're not
interrupting us
um and and so feel free
you know obviously there's no style
points for
for any of this so they're teenagers so
they don't
talk to me but uh it'll be more on
the video stream thank you
yeah no worries at all pam mr mr
chairman i i
neglected to um make sure that you read
the script at the opening of the
yes so i have that script anywhere
i emailed it to you i can email it to
you again
um actually what i was hoping to do
would do that with um
roll call so that we knew where we are
right the script ends with the uh roll
call the call for a roll call
so let me see if i can pull that up
sorry or uh
is that in the no that's not that
that's not that it should arrive any
second now
there it is script for friday
okay and this is what we need
to have done prior to every
meeting along with the pledge of
allegiance right
it's opening sorry um
and then vanessa so why don't vanessa
you run through
your uh no here we go
okay so the chairman script is now as
chair of the house legislative
administrative committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20204
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there are no
physical location there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
though the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
in rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
area code 603 271-3600
or email hcs
at leg.state.nh.us
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce pam smarling from
the house committee research who was on
the meeting assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
and that now it starts into let's start
the meeting by a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
somehow
how did that happen so none of that was
heard
no just the very end there some i don't
know what happened
we we heard you right up until right to
no law okay
great thanks dave um so vanessa i think
we are
good to go if you would like to
call the roll okay representative hill
here representative greene
here in hudson and i'm alone
representative packard representative
osborne
representative rouliard here
and we also need to say if anybody is in
the room with you right
representative simon here and i'm alone
representative wall here no one's with
me
representative lay i am here in jaffrey
and i am alone
representative smith present and alone
representative frost president in dover
i'm alone
representative nottingham i'm here i'm
in nashua uh my
son is next to me and then uh family's
coming through
representative espicia you're in nashua
and i'm alone
and did i pronounce your name correctly
it's a hearty it's espitia but
espitia okay thank you grace um
and i'm vanessa sheehan i'm here and i'm
alone
i neglected to say that i'm also alone
um learning curve it's all part of the
learning curve
um i think we so we left off
um with the committee hearings that
and i think we covered everything there
unless there was any
concerns or questions about that um
could i make a comment mr joe i was just
gonna
go ahead yeah i just wanted to note that
um
we we do need to use the elect better to
use the electronic
um hand raising feature
so it's it's natural and you know a more
casual setting to just
raise your hand i can't raise my hand
electronically because i'm the host
and i guess presumably i
you know shouldn't have to but um all of
you
have the ability to raise your hand by
by pressing the button at the end of the
bottom of the participants list there
should be
a raised hand option
probably um a co-host might not have
that
but it's something to be aware of and
when you do raise your hand
you um pop to the top of the list
in the order that those hands are raised
so the chairman can
call you in invoices yeah it is nice and
and you may sometimes deviate from that
i know if somebody has spoken a number
of times
you might say i'm gonna skip that person
because you know the second person
hasn't spoken at all yet
you know so that it's obviously your
choice but
it's it's handy because that happens in
the attendee side and also the panelists
side and it just
helps you maintain order do you know
pam y on my screen anyway
so claire claire's hand is raised but
then the
others are just a blinking red dot
is that is that indicating that they are
i'm sorry claire's hand um the others
don't
i i don't get i don't get any others
are you referring to the breaking red
dot that's in the uh participant window
yes because that means that just means
we're
recording the meeting right for the
three of us hosts i think that's what
that refers to
it is yes yeah it's that
cloud with a red dot in it it's a what
what is it
i don't know it looks like a it's like a
cloud symbol yeah
um okay so that means that uh
only the co-hosts are being recorded no
no no no the whole meeting
is being recorded i i frankly don't know
why
the request i think it just it just
reminds us
that we control that so claire's hand is
raised does that mean claire you would
no yes okay
my question is and i and i heard uh
everything i think about the hearings
and the hybrid the options for zoom in
the public for zoom
did we talk about exact session at all
and or did i miss that
um you have not missed that but i
haven't finished with the
with the committee hearing yet okay
there's some requirements with that as
well that need to be
um done pam do you have something else
first i just
while we're sort of still talking about
raising hands
you'll notice that representative
ruyard's hand is still
up she can lower it too and i think it's
handy if you
if each member raises and lowers their
own hands it's
it's otherwise they all stay up or or
you as the host can lower them
right but it's not it's one less thing
to do if
members raise their own hand and lower
it once they're recognized
thank you yeah oh sure this is this is
what we're here for to
kind of thing like having a rehearsed uh
committee meeting um so there are also
in this hybrid model we also have
responsibilities to
um to the committee and
one of which is you need to notify
bob the vice chair whether you intend to
be
in person or on zoom for that hearing
i'm assuming that has to do with making
sure that
the link goes to you that's correct and
that we end up with
everyone using the the panel list call
in and zoom link rather than
using the public one um which gets
a little bit to janet's question about
why does she show up as an
attendee rather than a panelist on on
here but um
i would think um it shouldn't be much
different
much of a heavy lift for people to just
get in touch with bob and say i plan on
being
in on zoom where i plan on being in the
hearing
is that correct pam is that the reason
why so that we know
who's who's here and why or where
they're supposed to be
well so we know who to send the links to
and
who to anticipate in the building so
it's it's
we're aware of who's in the building and
make sure that the seating will work and
whatever else might need to be done in
the room itself
to that end i would think we need to
have one
email address for everyone that's going
to be used
for this transmission of the link for
for zoom and we also need one telephone
number
so that we can identify who's calling in
and
and put them in the right spot i would
guess that's correct too pam
yes okay so um
if that can be provided um we really
don't have a chat
area or something but how would you like
pam that information to be transmitted
to
you or does that stay with bob
what that single number for everyone
would be um
the idea would be to use the same email
address
for all your legislative business
including the zoom
um links so that is
smith for um you know i think yesterday
he sent out an
uh an email to all members with that
request so if the clerk's office knows
um you know has that information then
then i can
get it from him for all of my committees
as so we have that central
location and then phone numbers
i think would be the same thing
certainly welcome to
to email me um as well
okay me on what you're sending me send
to paul just so i
have it as well but paul really is the
the central processing for
for contact information okay
um it's also a cautionary note that um
no one will
share that zoom link to with anyone else
um i asked today for
the the public email link um
which is available to share but um but
not the individual one that is sent to
each of us
um correct pam
yes that's correct if you share your
personal link
then we'd have a bunch of greg hills
is what's posted in the house calendar
it's publicly available
and therefore certainly very
appropriate to share all the committee
hearings will be
recorded will be on youtube um
even though the public will be
testifying only on
zoom um
i think that's everything i have on the
committee hearings anybody else have
you're good doug um no i just wanted to
just be clear so
if i just want to know for sure who do
we if i'm going to attend remotely or if
anybody's going to attend remotely
what's the advance notice you need how
how much in advance and
exactly who do we send it to do we send
it to bob uh representative green i'm
sorry
um or do we uh and and how far in
advance
would be necessary i just i just think i
just want to have that nailed down
that's all
i would say it's 24 hours um how i think
the
the catch is it pam when does the link
get
sent and then there's a reminder an hour
before
i'm caught in the binder i've been doing
it two days in advance
myself i know we're it we're entering
you know a general protocol that's
that's being developed right now so i
don't know if that's going to continue
to be the protocol
i'm sure that we'll know soon and then
we can
really firm up these these questions
it should go to representative green or
to to
to the committee assistant or
i think it would be handy for for
multiple community
services to know that or who i'm sorry
house committee services somebody in my
office you know
so again i'm going to make i'm making a
note of it you know
ann fitzgerald has asked us to to you
know maintain a list of all these types
of issues and questions to make sure
they're included in the final
protocols and so we'll okay
so to be determined i guess but but it
sounds like
two days is the default at this point 48
hours is the default and then if it
changes
i will let everyone know
there was one other thing that popped
into my head well oh and
so at this point i'll i'll go a little
bit behind the scenes
at um at some point all committee
hearings
we are going to have a double room
um in order to maintain social
distancing
at some point shortly i hope we will
have
the schedule of what days we will be
assigned for that double room
and um and that my understanding is we
will have the double room for
that day so it would be nice
just based on the number of bills we
have it would seem that we could almost
do
you know two full days um of hearings
and have that single double room and
and then schedule exec sessions and then
be out of here
um but that's the plan as it stands
i haven't i don't know what that day is
i've only heard from one person
so far that of a day that they can't
make
um hearings so it may be a good idea if
at some point
you shoot me a text or an email or
something and say
um you know these are these are
impossible days for me
um i i'm hopeful
that it's going to work out so everybody
is available when
we're supposed to be especially where
you don't have to drive
who knows an hour or two hours or three
hours to get here you know if you can
just take an hour out of your day
and be available for hearings that would
be great
um as soon as i know what day we've been
assigned
that's when i'll start working on
scheduling the hearings
so the more information that you give me
the better
um as far as trying to schedule all of
this
um that should cover hearings executive
sessions
um executive sessions will be
in person um executive sessions will be
in
the lob in this this room assigned to us
we don't have um the opportunity to zoom
executive sessions um that's
that's how things will be done we will
ask that all representatives if you can
make the if you can't make the executive
session you contact your
ranking member or maybe your deputy
ranking member i don't know that's up to
you
i'm going to ask all republicans will
get a hold of me
or vice chair green and
and let us know that's for purposes of
substitutes
um more than anything else
and at this point as soon as we know
we're going to have a great i you know
our first hearing i would think
there's going to be a whole bunch of new
information to be shared
i don't intend to
hold executive sessions on the days of
hearings
that's my intention who knows if in the
middle of a hearing we all look at each
other and say
this is a great idea let's all do it now
um
that will be noticed in the calendar
that we can do that
um but um but we will
hopefully hold all our hearings and then
hold uh
i would think an executive session day
and um and obviously if we can't do
if we're if we're going to be doing um
zoom
meetings and there's going to be a
hybrid setup of
in person and out of person or
in zoom in and in the lob
we really can't do an executive session
anyway if we're going to do
all of them in person so
that kind of will take care of itself
and that's all the questions i have
or all the answers i have at the moment
i'm willing to
if anybody has any questions on
executive sessions i don't see any hands
raised
we have three people with us today
i think that we invited
and these for the freshmen are usually
these are our um
you know round up the usual suspects
kind of people um
they are with us often in the in the
committee room
so i wanted to give them the opportunity
to address you
and tell you a little bit about what
they do
um it looks to me like terry
is the only oh no jim's on here as well
so
right now we have terry path
harry can i promote you or allow you to
talk here i'm going to try to get you
promote you to a panelist
there yet you see him
he's in a panelist column oh there we go
i got it it takes
a little lag he's somewhere in between
for a while but yeah
it's kind of like star trek when you uh
when they're
transmitted from yeah there looks like
i'm transmitted aboard the starship
yeah there you go oh look where you are
boy look at that
it looks pretty nice here in the notch
i've been uh following along via the
mobile
and so i'm hot spotting in right now
from verizon so
it's working well technology we've
really come a long way with technologies
all of you know
um so it's my job and for those of you
who don't hear me can you hear me all
right
everybody's nodding are you okay good
um for those of you who don't know i'm
the chief operating officer of the
general court so that's a newer position
it was established last year i'm a
former four-term
house chief of staff for several
different speakers
so we and i was a four-term member of
the house of representatives as well
so i've had a lot of experience in time
in
in the legislative branch and in the
general court itself and
as the chairman said and thank you mr
chairman for uh inviting us here we are
frequent visitors because a lot of what
you deal with the legislative
administration issues
are things that we have experienced with
and that we
work with through the process through
the facilities through access
issues so we under my purview and under
my responsibilities are the
ada access issues uh the department of
administration
or administration court administrative
office uh office of legislative services
the facilities themselves are under my
um office uh operations and
uh and your safety itself with our
psos our public safety officers and
chief burke who runs that division
so we it's really encompasses the
business of the legislature
is what i'm responsible for and
authorized by the principal officers
it's a joint position so all the people
i oversee
are joint employees um but really the
process in the physical plant
uh are some of the things that i come
visit you about and when there's
changes that are going to change and
affect
the institution either through process
or through physical plant issues
uh they come to your committee and i'll
be visiting you on those
i know uh representative wall has a bill
in that i'll be visiting you
on and that's about the uh upcoming
discussion on the uh on the portraits
and different collections throughout the
facility and there's a jurisdiction
issue that she's going to address with
her piece of legislation so i'll be
visiting you
testifying on that piece of legislation
but it's uh it's great to meet the new
members and
the former members and returning members
i should say
uh good to see you guys again and it'll
be interesting to see how this
all plans out now one of the areas of
responsibility i have is the gcts
division which is our it division and
that's been really uh
put to the test and we've done a lot of
recent building with our
it platforms lately and actually
preliminarily leading up to the pandemic
which was
which i wouldn't say is foresight i
thought it was uh it was more or less a
necessity because
we had so many legacy programs that we
were using to
promote our legislative process we
really had to get a consultant on board
and rebuild our whole platforms
right up and including our disaster
recovery platforms
so fortunately we did that we went to
the cloud we have the ability with teams
and other
software programs that we put in place
as well as rebuilding our full
server base and software protection and
virus protection capabilities so we've
done a lot of work there as well
so again i will be visiting you on a led
pieces of legislation that
uh that affect what i do and i oversee
and i'll also be available on a regular
basis along with attorney
um cianci it's a question uh
historically that we have some
experience with
that may come up within your committee
so mr chairman as always if
you need myself there or any members of
our the staff that i oversee for any
particular
issue or information you need i'm always
available for this committee
as any committee's really in the whole
general court but this one i'm in front
of quite often when uh
when pieces of legislation come up
affect the operations of the legislature
so with that i'll answer any questions
and then
see what i can help you with i
don't see any hands um
i think you're free to get back on the
slopes
all right thank you very much folks i'm
not heading the slope i'm heading to the
snowmobile trails but i'll try to
try to get there as well all right thank
you very much
carefully thanks look forward to working
with you
thank you gary bye-bye
um also on the list here is
jim cianci but now i see paul smith's
there um
jim i i wasn't sure whether you
had anything that you wanted to say i
will promote you to panelists
um and you're there
um is there anything that you would like
to
just say to our group mr chairman i
promoted um
paul smith at the same time oh yeah
oh jim if you're there yeah thank you mr
chairman
uh to introduce myself to the members of
the committee that i haven't met
uh jim c antion house legal counsel
you'll see me from time to time
sometimes testifying on bills
sometimes working with pam on background
information
paul terry and myself tend to
take an interest in this committee
because this committee's purview
is uh over matters which uh involve the
legislature itself sort of its internal
workings
so we tend to keep an eye out on those
issues and to provide you with the best
information to make your decisions
um one thing and paul can jump here in
here as well
uh mr chairman uh the discussion about
executive sessions
um we were at the chairs meeting this
morning and our understanding is that
the
um executive sessions are going to be
conducted uh remotely or
on the hybrid uh model over zoom
we're not aware that that any decision
has been made that those are going to
have to be in person um and that's of
this morning at the chairs meeting and
i'll let paul jump in as well
uh yeah mr chairman thank you uh just
and i did just confirm with the speaker
uh that that members um are able to
participate remotely for executive
sessions
um the the caveat is that
uh members do have to be visible on
screen
um for uh for an executive session
uh for voting purposes uh and that is to
to verify
um their votes and that that is also
pursuant
uh to our new section of mason's manual
as well
that that does have a brand new chapter
on remote hearings
um in in sort of establishing guidelines
on determining
this is all good reason why we have you
folks here today
so is there were there any other items
that
came up in the chairs meeting that
obviously i missed that uh
that should have been that should be of
interest to
the committee uh actually uh yes mr
chairman if you don't mind um
i i would just would just let you know
that there is going to be a new um
uh a new tool for testifying on
legislation
uh that is being worked out on our web
where people will be able to file
essentially a pink card
right out on the website and at the end
of of their
sort of registration process there is an
email link that will direct
them to send an email to the committee
if they have testimony that they wish to
be
included so this is this is something
that that
literally has been rolled out today um
and uh it is if you're interested to see
how it looks it is actually live on the
senate uh page as well
they they uh they started this week uh
in earnest with their hearings as well
and and have been utilizing the system
uh some of the back end uh stuff on how
uh to um determine the order of
testimony and those sorts of things
those those details will be worked out
individually
uh with you and and your committee
technical person
um and uh we'll we'll go from there
but i just wanted to uh to mention that
that that is uh
that is sort of a new obviously piece to
our legislative landscape here
how about blue sheets uh so
so it's the same thing so essentially
what what it is is you
you sign up on the website and um
it's you either market you're you're in
favor or opposed
and you also uh mark if you want to
speak
uh so it's it's uh very similar to to
how we have it set up now except we've
sort of combined
both forms into one it actually would
look a lot like what we were used to
with the senate
it it yeah i i didn't want to use those
yes we are we are we are making those
folks
um anything else paul that you would
like to discuss with the committee
members
uh thanks mr chairman yes um i i i
i think you all know me um i'm paul
smith i'm your your house clerk
um you uh yes this is this is basically
the only committee i hang out in
um uh with with no disrespect to the
other committees this is the one
though that obviously has uh the most
meaning for
uh for for what we do internally in our
processes and that's why
you will see me from time to time uh
chiming in on legislation
um and and usually uh well always i
don't take a position on the legislation
i simply
present to you sort of information uh as
i have it historical pieces that sort of
thing
um so uh you know if you do see me it's
it's not because
um i i'm unhappy or or i'm trying to
give you heartburn
it's just because i just uh you know
there's there's
um well and i'm sure having looked at
the legislation that's before your
committee
i'm sure you can you can understand why
you'll probably be seeing me
on some of those issues so the heartburn
is just
a side benefit i know the heartburn is
is usually on my end
based on based on uh you know various
interpretations of rules and whatnot
[Laughter]
so for um new members
you should realize that paul used to be
one of us
um how many years were you
just um you know it was it was it was a
long time ago uh when when i didn't have
any of these things
um yes when i was uh when i was actually
when i was a senior in college i ran for
a seat in the house
and i actually served on this committee
so that's why i
i and i was a clerk in my second term of
this committee so i obviously i feel a
great attachment to legislative
administration for
a variety of reasons great
um i'm hopeful i didn't cut off jim did
you
um did you have a war that you wanted to
include or
uh we kind of got sidetracked with the
idea of uh
executive sessions thank you mr chairman
actually all i'll say is uh ditto
you'll tend to see the two of us
together because we
you know paul takes a lot of times the
historical aspect the rules aspect
i'll take the legal aspect they
intertwine and again
as paul said i'm i if i do come to
testify
it will never be to take a position on a
bill um but it will just
be to point out maybe technical defects
in a bill
or to provide you with information that
may not be apparent from the bill
as much as pam is your your researcher
and your resource for the committee
you should also consider and paul and
terry as you heard
as a resource to this committee just
based upon the nature of the
the subject matter that you deal with so
thank you
thank you um are either of you willing
to
so representative richard i've
unmuted you um you have a question you
have your hand up
i do um thank you mr chairman
um paul you referenced um
the new section in masons
um and was that i forgive me i have not
read the entire calendar
um was that included in there or
a place for us to link and review that
section ourselves
well so um mason's
is unfortunately extremely copyrighted
uh the uh the um the various leadership
offices do have several copies
um and you are certainly able to
purchase a copy yourself
either a hardbound uh i will also
mention um that for the first time
uh we do have a digital version uh where
you can download the digital version
um and it is a a reduced cost you do
have to have a
log in on the ncsl website ncsl
publishes
um the mason's manual every every 10
years
the the work however is produced by
my association the uh the american
society of legislative clerks and
secretaries we have a commission
that is a 10-year commission that works
on on updating those things
um but there is a new chapter chapter 57
um and it begins with 32 and it talks
specifically about
uh remote meetings and and the reason i
mention that is because although
um in our our rules that we've adopted
our emergency rules we reference
certain things um and and we also as you
heard at the beginning of the meeting
reference the governor's emergency order
and those sorts of things
uh there is guidance uh so in the event
that the emergency order goes away and
our rules expire
um there is guidance for how we could
conduct
um these these hearings in a remote
fashion um
you know provided we we do establish
some to do that
so so you know that's that's why i
mentioned
specifically we we do sort of have some
some guidance
on on how to conduct these uh these
meetings beyond
uh just the emergency order which we've
anyone else i don't see any other hands
raised anywhere
um i think i think you guys are
uh representative wall did you have a
question
um i i have a concern i cannot meet on
fridays
because i work on fridays and i need to
put that out there right now i um i had
a note of that
from someone maybe pam um
and um and i've made that known to
um to everyone i can that we have a
scheduling issue
for thank you for fridays um
anyone else that has those issues please
shoot me a an email or a text which is a
good segue for me to give you my email
and my
telephone number um mr chairman i'm
sorry i just need to log off
i just wanted to uh thank you for the
opportunity to say hi um
and uh also to uh uh to wish
representative frost a happy birthday
and also to say hi to
thank you all and i hope you have a
um and i think jim are you uh you
also are free to go if you'd like
great thank you mr chairman appreciate
it good to see you thanks for coming
um so i was heading into
a cell phone number and a um an email
so email for me is great um it would be
uh greg hill greg
hill nh like new hampshire
and cell number would be
six one seven five nine zero
four
what is that four zero one two seven
everyone good with that um i don't know
if bob
um would also like to provide
his um being that he would be the one
that would need to be in touch with so
i'll remind you that we're on youtube
right now good point just
let's see so we will we will provide
that to you
how's that yeah that would be great
thanks for a reminder yeah thank you uh
10 seconds too late pam
thank you um because i heard you like
does the chat go to you
no um so let's um
i don't think that there's any other
things uh
needed to be covered if anybody can
think of anything that we didn't cover
that we should have
um we i see no hands i see no
i think we're good okay i think we are
good
um with that i will accept a motion to
adjourn
so moved that's always that's always
the top person in
motion thanks very much everyone uh
talk to you soon as soon as i know a
date we will we'll be in touch